eigentlich dehnt sich das universum seit
dem urknall unaufhörlich aus trotzdem
ziehen sich die galaxien und
galaxienhaufen gegenseitig an
neueste forschungsergebnisse besagen
dass unsere milchstraße auf einen großen
sternen verschlingt zusteuert jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction
bis zu einer entfernung von bis zu
mehreren hundert millionen lichtjahren
zieht der große sternen verschlinge der
sogenannte attraktor sternen inseln wie
ein riesiger staubsauger an und unsere
milchstraße steuer direkt darauf zu
meinen jetzt die wissenschaftler auf
rennt julie aus hawaii und elend kauerte
aus frankreich darf kamen die forscher
als sie in die zukunft des weltalls und
besonders unserer milchstraße blickten
in einer simulation haben sie das
visualisiert was vermutlich in der
zukunft passieren wird
für die astronomen herausfanden steht
unsere milchstraße am rand eines
galaxien superhaufen deren durchmesser
von 520 millionen lichtjahren aufweist
wobei das ist im weltall nicht besonders
roses hat jan durchmesser von mehr als
45 milliarden lichtjahren in diesen
galaxien superhaufen sind als 100.000
aktien enthalten diesen super hoffen
haben die forscher janiak er getauft
das bedeutet auf hawaiianisch
unermesslicher himmel um erstmal zu
wissen wo genau unsere milchstraße in
dieser galaxien ansammlung steckt haben
die wissenschaftler die
geschwindigkeiten der sternen inseln in
der nachbarschaft berechnet so kamen sie
auf die wechselseitigen gravitative
einflüsse also die anziehungskräfte der
galaxien untereinander
die mussten sie aus der ausdehnung des
universums herausrechnen
denn bereits seit anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts war für die wissenschaft
klar
seit dem urknall dehnt sich das weltall
aus zwölf entdeckte der amerikanische
astronom wessels leifer dass die
spektrallinien des lichts weit
entfernter galaxien in den roten bereich
des spektrums verschoben sind ein effekt
der durch die ausdehnung der raumzeit
seit dem urknall hervorgerufen und kurz
darauf bemerkte edwin hubble dass das
licht von galaxien eine größe
rotverschiebung hat wenn sie in größerer
entfernung für uns stehen die 127 zog
der belgische priester und kosmologe
georges lemaitre eine kühne
schlussfolgerung aus diesen
beobachtungen die ausdehnung des
universums musste vor endlicher zeit in
einem einzigen punkt begonnen habe
dieses ereignis käme heute alle als der
urknall und genau mit der ausdehnung des
universums hatten die forscher ihre
probleme schwierigkeiten hatten sie bei
ihrer simulation nämlich mit der
trennung der geschwindigkeits
komponenten denn einerseits gibt es die
bewegung die durch die expansion des
alls hervorgerufen wird und andererseits
die anziehungskräfte der materie im
weltall
das haben die wissenschaftler allerdings
mit einem speziell entwickelten
computerprogramm heraus rechnen können
die größte anziehungskraft hat demnach
der große attraktor er besteht aus dem
norma und centaurus hoffen und darauf
legt sich unsere milchstraße zu der
große attraktor besteht auf mehreren
zehntausend maxim hat also eine sehr
große menge an materie diese galaxien
sind zwischen 150 bis 250 millionen
lichtjahre von der milchstraße entfernt
die komplexität die wir in diesem
kosmischen flut sehen ist beinahe
überwältigend meinte die studien
hauptautor in mode war in ihrer
simulation haben die wissenschaftler
auch die zukünftige bahn der milchstraße
errechnet demzufolge steuern wir auf den
großen attraktor zu 2004 wurde übrigens
die kollision zweier galaxien hoffen
beobachtet die nasa zeigt hier in einer
animation im zeitraffer wie sie
abgelaufen ist
allerdings ist es eher unwahrscheinlich
dass wir je dort ankommen denn dass
galaxien gewinne des traktors fliegt
durch die ausdehnung des weltalls
schneller davon als die milchstraße
angezogen war doch eine andere kollision
wird mit sicherheit stattfinden
in etwa vier milliarden jahren wird
unsere milchstraße mit dem andromeda
nebel kollidieren er ist nur 2,5
millionen lichtjahre entfernt um rat mit
114 kilometern pro sekunde auf uns zu
mit ihm wird unsere milchstraße zu einer
neuen großen galaxie verschmelzen
triebfeder hinter diesem unglaublichen
schauspiel ist die dunkle materie die
deutlich mehr wasser enthält als die
sichtbare materie genau fünf mal mehr
was hinter ihr steckt wird in zukunft
sicher noch für einige überraschungen
sorgen
erste spuren sind ja wahrscheinlich
schon entdeckt worden
darüber wer in diesem video hier dunkle
materie gefunden dafür hier klicken
täglich wissenschaften uns gibt es im
blog und der app dafür klingen
allerdings auch in der video
beschreibung und was meint ihr was
passiert da draußen
wie ist das alles entstanden und wohin
wird sich das universum entwickeln ich
bin ehrlich gesagt vollkommen sprachlos
wenn ich so etwas sehe diskutiert es mit
mir in den kommentaren und jetzt heißt
es abschied nehmen bis zum nächsten
video bis dann bleibt kann